[Musique]
pardon madame s'il vous plaît pour aller
place de la concorde à pied auger pas
non il ne fait pas froid non non non
nous n'est acquis la bicyclette oui
c'est ça mais auquel ça abon par là bas
alors oui la droite
la coca nicolas courtois avec qui je
vais les autobus vous dites parce que
j'ai des chaussures oui sur ses jolies
chaussures
bon elle est rené tobie pardon hein
établissent à non pas du tout à nos noms
à nora non ça je vais plus qu il peut
pas faire c'est pas possible si j'y vais
toutes façons
vous ne savez pas à
monsieur s'il vous plaît
pour aller à la place de la concorde
s'il vous plaît à pied je suis rangé
dans la voiture est ici quelques pieds
carrés de toiture à droite ou à gauche
par là où par la famille eyadéma vous
dites 1a l'alma vous avez une voiture
vous voulez y aller en voiture à la
concorde
enfin j'ai pas vu monsieur arthur non ce
qui le monsieur arthur vous dites on dit
bien vous l'avez place de la concorde
c'est ça non pour la tour eiffel oui je
ne il faut passer par la tour eiffel ou
mieux de demander la concorde
c'est ça non et si vous m'avez demandé à
- comment qu'est ce que vous me le
demandez moi mais pas ce matin parce que
je n'y étais pas là ce matin je suis pas
venu ce matin il ya un quart d'heure je
suis la série qui suit vous voulez faire
pardon qu'est ce que vous voulez faire
un représentant dans le temps vous dit
le temps pour y aller à la concorde ou
ou et allait ou non je n'ai pas tacher
ma voiture avec une corde non je suis
rangé la sur le sur le trottoir je
voulais rouler là vous êtes là au
champ-de-mars la lah pour la place de la
concorde vous avez nous la droite place
et la concorde un quart d'heure 15
minutes à pied
à
ou en voiture oui bah ça a joué dur
comme ça comme ça tout droit non je sais
bien je peux pas me garer c'est pour ça
je vous demandais on peut se les ont
peur on peut rester là on peut se garer
allez lâchez vous n'êtes pas grand sens
interdits se valent
ça va très bien moins aisée car
l'allemagne l'a alors vous me dites
l'alma llena il avril bien la scène il
alors vous êtes perdus madame hélène qui
est vrai c'est celle là dans la danse ça
vous me dites à bombay pourquoi vous me
dites de monter un agent à huy peux pas
vous répondre moi tu peux livrer les
agents et moi pourquoi ou une petite
flûte dit pourquoi vous me dites flûte
excuse à ce que j'entends pas bien non
monsieur moi je prends mon service et à
présent c'est pourtant vrai 10h chez lui
vous voulez savoir l'heure il est 10h
hagard mois - 10h45 22h45 les
renseignements les agents vont à huy
abord merci
textron il ya peu le taxi pour aller
alors sur la scène vous avez les bateaux
mouches qu'on attend mais je devais une
voiture une un taxi une voiture autour
ou pas je ne connais pas la chaire dur
vous voulez dire non non non non non non
pardon parce que je n'ai je l'entends
pas très un taxi une voiture un
chauffeur une voiture pour m'en aller
vous voulez tout à l'heure pour venir
revenir ici tout à l'heure avec vous
avez rendez vous c'est salomon aller non
non non non non non celle ci s est mal
garées sur la route youdé cherche une
voiture pardon parce que je cherche une
voiture un taxi un chauffeur à monsieur
arthur alors c'est l'administration qui
fois les demandes est bon parce que si
vous voulez visiter paris vous avez le
trocadéro ici c'est ça que vous vouliez
j'ai bien compris vous il ya les autres
cadets et ensuite faire la tournée sur
l'a16 amérique le bateau est oui alors
c'est là leur foute monsieur arthur faut
demander à monsieur arthur c'est ce que
vous me disiez ouverture c dans l'air au
bureau d'administration très bien vous
vouliez quelque chose d'autre monsieur
rabon merci dit monsieur monsieur vous
habitez paris
comment non non vous êtes de clichy non
je n'habite pas paris
ah bon parce que hyper excusez moi
monsieur venez venez venez aux eaux
avec un pot de peinture le voyou oh ça
c'est scandaleux
il est temps travaillez-vous jacarei est
en train de peindre ce banc j'espère que
ce n'est pas quand même dans le but de
faire se tacher d'innocents promeneurs
ça serait bête et méchant
[Musique]
vous avez peut-être eu intérêt à prendre
un pistolet pour faire tout ça
[Musique]
l'accompagnement musical que vous
entendez actuellement et est une
improvisation de janvier nerfs au piano
près de moi
[Musique]
voilà jacques harry s'installe bien
confortablement
se frotte pour que la peinture
s'imbriquent bien à son veston
il va se diriger maintenant vers un
autre banc avant lui parfaitement au sec
cette fois ci ce soit à côté de ces
messieurs qui ne se doute de rien
il va commencer par se faire remarquer
jacques harry par des tic par des gestes
insolite un comportement bizarre
quelle va être la réaction de ces
messieurs en voyant le dos trier de
notre ami c'est ce que nous allons voir
ensemble
[Musique]
enfin
allez on efface tout et on recommence
avec une autre personne
[Musique]
et
attendez attendez attendez on va voir ce
qu'on va voir si ça marche vraiment à
tout les coup dans l'ailé
à
en
[Musique]
réflexe nuancé
cruel dilemme eh bien puisque vous êtes
sages nous allons vous offrir une
quatrième petite expérience
[Musique]
mes actions brutales
des motifs sur le corsage mais pourra de
rec
tous
non
pardon national vous en prie monsieur
restez-vous ici au moins de trois
minutes
nos trois minutes pas plus d'abord merci
parce que j'attends mon patron je vous
le dis n'est ce pas ce que vous cherchez
pourquoi je vois ce que tu service
pourriez vous gardez la clique car la
voiture que les fermiers
s'il arrive qu'ils ne soient pas la
porte mais on va le donner à n'importe
qui a non non le monsieur vous gérez
après les fera sa voiture ici je suis
sûre cet acte avec la petit tour à pied
j'ai tellement de trucs alors il vous
verrez parce qu'il connaît sa voiture
merci maladie puis que j'arrive en trois
minutes
merci dans la guerre civile il est bien
police pensait lui toile à la situation
est établie en tout cas dans quelques
instants
jacques balutin va essayer d'entrer dans
cette belle voiture
seulement ces personnes vont elles
croire qu'il s'agit du propriétaire ou
au contraire vont-elles défendre
farouchement l'objet qu'il aura été
confiée au père qui sont le temps
d'attendre surtout
évidemment ça peut paraître bizarre un
monsieur qui vous confie les clés de sa
voiture
entrée 2 balutin
que vous
bah je regarde la voiture pourquoi c'est
votre voiture et non jaune en mai m
le courtier est pas monté dans ma toile
comme si je suis fatigué je me repose a
fermé ses cellules
mais quel talent ou non bah ouais ouais
vous pourriez vous en prie fermé elle
permet la poursuite affirme mais vous
avez la clé mais pourquoi comment ça se
déroule à donner mais oui ou là de la
garder comme ça va dire que c'est lui
qui va là parce que ce sera toujours lui
demandait
non il faut avoir peur à côté de moi
même si j'ai dit que je vous emmène avec
moi et ma peau mais si vous le demandez
pour moi cette heure mais peut-être que
si vous lui demandez pour moi il me fera
peur à dos il nous fait là bas pour
monter dans la voiture parce qu'il est
ici d'ouvrir je lui ai demandé qu'est ce
qu'il fait c'est laid le monsieur pardon
monsieur excusez moi mais je vous
attendais pas en tenue de travail
parlons iphone os et ça c'était un
battant je suis allée l'onda
[Applaudissements]
pardon mais c'est bien
je vous remercie beaucoup du service que
vous avez envie n'a rien n'était pas en
colère après moi ce monsieur
aussi je fais du cinéma comme un film
funny tournage il a dit nous tournons un
film tous ensemble en ce moment c'est
une émission de l'alerté est donnée
tournez-vous szczecin est stable et nous
avons fait un sens un petit film pour
une émission qui s'appelle la caméra
invisible et vous avez répondu très
gentiment d'ailleurs à la tels que je
vous ai lancé de vous conservez cette
clé madame merci
/
oui je sais vous cherchez l'issue c'est
une erreur regrettable
certains veulent un peu à la c4
malheureusement vous savez ça s'est
passé très rapidement mais une erreur
qui a été fait
alors nous avons été téléphoné à la
préfecture de versailles
nous n'y en a pas pour très longtemps on
va voir immédiatement le l'issue
dégageable tout va alors je vais vous
demander de tourner un peu circulé
non
à l'occasion un starbucks
quelques instants madame tournée
c'est monsieur principe à ses principes
il s'agit mademoiselle d'une erreur de
la préfecture de versailles alors nous
avons été téléphoner on va dégager une
des six que je vais vous demander de
tourner pendant quelques instants s'il
vous plaît
nous sommes allés téléphone et on va
dégager une des issues dans quelques
instants
je vous demanderais de tourner très
lentement pour ne pas consommer trop
d'essence tournée très long et très
lentement et nous nous débarrassions
tout de suite nous dégageons ici s'il
vous plaît oui monsieur madame
si l'on veut oui je vais vous demander
de tourner très lentement pendant
quelques instants on est allé téléphoné
je comprends bien madame
[Musique]
par ici par ici même
c'est
je vais vous demander de tourner très
lentement pendant quelques instants
téléphoner exit joe thomas mann prise
danois
on est a dû téléphoner monsieur vous
serez des gars dégagés dans quelques
instants
alors je vais vous demander tournée très
lentement
[Musique]
donner je sais bien madame mais c'est
une erreur de là c'est une erreur de la
préfecture nous sommes aussi téléphoner
nous dégageons une issue dans quelques
instants
je vous en prie tourner lentement non
malheureusement le stationnement est
interdit et c
je voudrais payer quelques instants
seulement
celle ci dessus
ici
m
[Musique]